scp-6819 is a phenomenon classified as
ketter or uncontained by the SCP
Foundation occurring on highways in the
U.S numbered highway system this
phenomenon causes sudden translocation
of a vehicle to an extra dimensional
region
scp-6819-1 and its subsequent return
this event can only be triggered under
specific conditions the driver must be a
current or former Foundation employee
the vehicle must be moving independently
between 11 pm and 4 AM local time zone
the moon must be in a waning phase and
there must be no more than three
passengers in the vehicle including the
driver once in
scp-6819-1 there is always an event that
encourages the driver to slow down stop
or exit the vehicle but the specific
nature of these events varies Foundation
protocol advises against travel during
trigger hours or else to travel in
groups and never stop exit the vehicle
or approach the mysterious building
Research into
scp-6819 continues